plus loin
ou non
Yo
bien
et les filles
ouvre-moi la porte
une semaine s'étire et un pas change
une bougie a été allumée et un chapeau
va courir moi et mon garçon
comment ça a été aujourd'hui
Dans mon quartier
où est-ce que je dis dieu
où je vis dieu une histoire d'amour avec
un autre sens où je vis
Je vis
5 sur le balcon c'est un mec de l'extérieur
quand un mec sur le balcon
au balcon
fille il y a un mec sur le balcon dans le
balcon
et ici
fille
ouvre-moi la porte
du bas bon bruit et un bisou ma
pour finir le téléviseur s'allume et
le miroir qui répond a l'air bien là
garçons qui
viens tôt je suis mon histoire d'amour
Dans mon quartier
où j'habite
Histoires d'amour
avec 22 autres où j'habite
Je vis
sur le balcon il y a un mec de dehors
il a dit sur le balcon et c'était sur le balcon
regarde regarde il y a
de la fille de la loi
il y a un mec sur le balcon
et dans la maison de rita un petit garçon sec
dit que personne ne le connaît mais elle l'a invité
ses amis la protègent et la protègent dans le
porte et vient maintenant bob et rangers qui
il me touche
maintenant je vais
avec une sorte d'amour
regarde regarde regarde regarde regarde regarde
regarde le gars hey regarde regarde c'était
un gars de l'extérieur a mis le blâme sur
rita le combattre la faute est trenc sr
et je vais chercher du pain
une sorte d'amour pour ce mec qui est sorti
courir vers ce gars que je connais
Je suis le type d'amour, il y a un type dedans
bateau il y a un type
Regarde ça
petit à petit
Dans la loi
et
nouveau
Donc